[Music]
I'm pretty happy last night was all
about Casey tonight is all about you you
wrote this film you directed it you
produce it you start in it what does it
mean to have such an incredible moment
for your family for the Affleck's and
share this together see I'm proud of
this movie I really am but the
overwhelming sense I had last night
watch my brother win and believing in
him for so long and knowing how talented
he is and not seeing him get the chance
to show that it was the most memorable
experience of my life last night I'm
thrilled I wish him the best but already
what he's done is amazing we talked to
Casey last night and winners walk he
said he always asked you for advice and
you never give it to him why is that he
doesn't need any advice my brother's one
of the smartest guys I know he's savvy
he's smart he's talented he's thoughtful
he just knows what he's doing he doesn't
need me help to help him
was the most memorable moment for you
guys in terms of celebrating last night
we stood out a little late by night last
night soon but I wasn't too bad I had to
get up and take the kids to school so
responsibilities were still calling matt
has come out to celebrate you and
support you tonight what does it mean to
you to have that kind of friendship a
long-standing bond I can't tell you how
valuable it is to have somebody who's
been through things with you ups and
downs who knows what your life
experience is like we're going to
identify with that it's an incredibly
valuable friendship and it's very
precious and so is my friendship with my
brother I don't know what I would do
without those guys
you
you